[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody to my brand new show
called main review somebody touch my
spaghetti me review ugandan knuckles
everybody can someone please help these
poor knuckles find the way they are
looking for their next me number 15
Burger King foot ladders the last thing
you want in your burger king burger is
foot fungus but as it turns out that my
what'd you get me review that's right
I'm back after two days with another
meme review oh the disintegration mean
yes of course this is blowing up the
same day that I posted my last one and I
all the sudden now all the sudden
everyone's like me and the distant rain
should meme it's so funny it's so funny
looking at Shrek
a donkey I don't feel so good this is so
sad because Shrek has swamp sense which
means that he knew he was about to die
that Jude oh so sad this meme is so sad
so last meme review i reviewed marvel
infinity war means i didn't bring up the
disintegration meme cuz it's not that
funny it's not that great
it's it's not even chuckle worthy it
makes me actually want to die which
gives it a little bit more points but
nevertheless I see what I must do now if
I hold the power in my hands that every
time I clapper me a mean dice if not
that is not actually a joke but truth
itself that is not only my duty but my
privilege to review the disintegration
mean because this is garbage okay if you
don't want to if you don't even know
where how bad this is New York Times is
I was called Times Magazine has reviewed
this me what polygon has reviewed this
what am I gonna do if you're not
familiar with marvelous infinite war
movie let's give it a little bit of
context so you understand here's the
basic plot summarize
[Music]
panos you are defeated negative stalls
[Music]
fanos nothing is happening
[Music]
[Music]
pretty moving pretty emotional stuff a
lot of characters died in the movie
everyone's favorite superhero and I
understand this meme immediately gets
the seal of containers approval you are
allowed to cry over this mean everything
is just dissing degrading left and right
what meme is going to be destroyed next
who knows any meme that goes mainstream
will of course get the lost version of
it okay we're fine that was sexy pretty
good sorry this is so sad leave early
can we hit a thousand brighter people
run from me hey hey who did this not
cool
delete delete this right now delete I'm
not laughing I'm not doing this rude I
hate this me stop it with this stuff for
me
drink what
where's door hole
those weren't there she had druid with
match mark
we were supposed to cut it out with the
power shop but I'm gonna
oh really yes so go get the power saw
okay I will
I'm shaking I never been this max can
you stop disintegrating everything not
broke my only friend ah not spongebob
when will it end
oh look it's me because I'm crying yeah
anyone that cries just has stood by the
way was not crying
that was fabricated tears y'all fell for
it scientists say this is the last thing
a meme sees I don't feel so good this is
funny because when Gandalf died in Lord
of the Rings he disintegrated into
little it makes sense whenever I see the
disintegration mean I wish I was being
disintegrated so long partner I don't
feel so good oh no Canada is
disintegrating everybody what are we
going to do what are we going to do
without Canada oh no not Canada Oh
Canada
I bet Canada knew that it was going to
die because Canada has the cook sense Oh
Zach I knew it would suck behind this
who else has this power what the hell is
this even supposed to mean I'm not even
crying in this do you think I'm some soy
boy I never cried in my entire life
don't make me laugh it's the only way
Luigi why is it disintegrating just the
best the most hurtful way to see someone
go and if they just go yeah it's not a
sad it's just disappearing and fading
into dust but can you do it here hey
another dead meat this is actually a
photorealistic image of what happens
when the memes does in fact diet that's
right types of migraines migraine
hypertension stress enough he'll hook
filthy Frank Joe gee why did you have to
do it meme review memes Hey look at that
everybody someone got into joining them
the jokes they did it to me
hey Jess hey grande stop it stop it stop
that I could snap my fingers and boners
mean would cease to exist oh it all
makes sense
guess I'll die that's a pretty good one
hey look it's my beard disintegrating
that is his right I actually didn't have
to shave it was pretty pretty convenient
and easy
please stop the disintegration god damn
everyone knows the original
disintegrator wish it was of course the
windows 95 logo this is actually an
old-school meme not a lot of people know
about it but now you do know because
here at meme review we care about
educating you make you smarter make you
think superintendent I don't feel so
good this is the steamed hams memes by
the way I haven't reviewed it but it's
probably one of the greatest means of
all time it's just comic sketch from The
Simpsons and that's it mr. stark I don't
feel so good that is so funny
all the memes are just dying just
because I'm clamping doesn't mean any
memes are dying alright this is
literally just me doing the main review
me reviewer everybody main review let
all the memes die you know what I don't
care it would be better to let everyone
die can't we do that instead nothing
it's not working it's not working
stop it this mean gets why I'm mean
review I know what you're thinking do we
have time for bonus meme Felix this is a
garbage episode with a garbage meme
honestly you really just melt this
didn't you
excuse me no no that's not true at all
what do you think I'm some greedy greedy
bastard
leave a like if you like to likes things
and if you don't then please go ahead
and subscribe to this channel right now
because I don't like anything I either I
think we will have a really great time
you and I together let's go on an
adventure together this has been pretty
pie goodbye everybody
oh and also don't forget to check out
merch represent calm / pewter paths only
two days left until next time main
review
[Music]